I'm Charlie demilio and I'm Dixie
demilio and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
I don't know which one it is
[Music]
yay first one what is Charlie demilio's
most viral Tick Tock I think it has to
be a dancing one I really don't look at
my videos that much after I post them
I'll look through some comments but I
don't really check if it's viral or not
okay what was Charlie demilio's old tick
tock username originally it was my name
and then I changed it it was Charles Dan
and then I changed it back to Charlie
demilia I definitely have
accounts that I use to look at people's
stories so they can't on Tech talk tell
them it's me Instagram I have quite a
few what phone does Charlie demilio use
I have an iPhone 13 a small one yeah but
not the really small one I filmed my
tick tocks on my phone in The Tick Tock
app sometimes they're not the best
quality I notice if I post
when I don't have like the best service
or something I feel like people think
everything is so much more staged and
planned and like curated than it is I
don't think things do that no it's
really not at all what is Charlie
demilio most used nickname
Charles Charles Charles Landon called
you something funny
um Char Bar Char Bar chunk was a
nickname yeah long time chunking
what Dixie demilia you ready no I'm
nervous what
songs has Dixie demilio made you think I
can name them all yeah all right be
happy Be Happy remix another Be Happy
remix probably one more I don't remember
F boy naughty list roommates one whole
day and then an album I'm not a great
remember usually remember remember yeah
what's your eye
I don't know an eyelash problem what is
Dixie dimilio show called Dixie Emilio
show that's what I call it but it's like
the early late night show it has yeah
has a bunch of names I feel something in
my eye now yeah I see it that's why I
was
confused what sport did Dixie demilio
play I'll do my biggest Sports BMX which
I was pretty good at track and field
cross country and field hockey I also
did like swimming and basketball and
soccer tennis I tried lacrosse I'm
really bad yeah that's it very athletic
boxing what is Dixie dimilio
Instagram spam why don't you say it for
the for the people it's called
um my
Dixie
wrecked I have a couple but that's like
my main spam that everyone follows and I
didn't know what the meaning behind it
was I just saw it was like a cool name
and then I got in trouble by my parents
but I don't get it I don't know why they
got mad that showed some name because
it's funny
yeah it's okay what does Dixie demilio
eat for breakfast sometimes I'll eat
something crazy and then sometimes I
just like can't eat breakfast today I
had a everything bagel toaster cream
cheese and then bacon and a donut and a
bunch of munchkins the mini donut holes
then I felt sick and I had to go to bed
immediately because there was so much
food I usually don't eat breakfast
because it kind of grosses me out
Charlie
yay what is Charlie demilio Dunkin
Donuts drink
a cold brew with four milk three sugar
it's pretty good I like it what does
Charlie demilio smell like born dreamer
yeah I I that's my scent I guess
um what am I smelling right now you
smell like it oh it's very faded right
now because you've been up since 1am
yeah who did Charlie demilio go to prom
with I went to prom with Billy Bennett
we've been great friends for a very long
time and we had a great prom night it
was very fun it was sweet yeah he asked
me in a cute way like a thousand people
yeah he invited like all of the boys and
all the girls were there too yeah it was
cute where Charlie demilio gets her
clothes I would say social tourist I get
a lot of skins shoes wise I pretty much
just wear the same pair of Puma shoes
everything oh thanks they're actually
hers I still thought yeah so thank you
who does Charlie demilio follow on Tick
Tock I follow a bunch of people I feel
like I accidentally follow people a lot
I follow anyone I think is funny I don't
really follow people that often I save
everything now yeah but now they get
alerts if you save videos which is the
scariest thing ever yeah
yeah
no more stalking or like if I want to
listen before it's gone
Dixie demilio it is Dixie demilio
emo I don't think I give off those vibes
but
as Dixie demilio coming out with a new
song
yes
at some point I could tell you nothing
about the song because I don't know but
I know there's a date floating around
have you made it yeah I like it's it's
made it's been made for like eight
months oh is Dixie demilio coming to
Qatar I want to so badly I want to go
that's where the World Cup is yeah it's
Dixie demilio
Charlie twin no we're not twins but
everyone always thinks you're older than
I am I think we've been looking more and
more similar recently yeah especially
when we do our hair the same I don't
know today but yesterday
is Dixie demilio missing what no
am I I don't think so
hopefully not I'm here she's gotta pay
rent hey how long has Charlie demilio
been on Tick Tock since I was 15 and I'm
18 now so three years is Charlie demilio
kid friendly I would say yes oh like
kid-friendly like family friendly I
thought I meant you were nice to kids
I would say
um yes and no mostly no because I curse
and such I mean I don't do like crazy
things are you friendly to kids uh I
would say I will wave at them okay how
did Charlie demilio learn
to dance in dance class
that's kind of I've been doing that
since ever so
I think that's where I got it good is
Charlie demilio leaving Tick Tock are
you I am not leaving Tick Tock I don't
plan on leaving I don't want to leave
good can Charlie demilio
do a backflip I cannot do a backflip I
can do a back handspring I have a fear
of jumping backwards without my hands
well I used to be a diver I was doing a
dive and I hit the board and that was
like really traumatizing to me and I
just could never like go backwards
except for a back handspring I need my
hands there
does Dixie demilio
like penguins yeah I did a show in
Philly for Jingle Ball and I got to meet
a penguin and also in our hometown
aquarium they have penguins come every
winter and there's one named Dixie which
was really cool so it's the first Dixie
I've ever met
does Dixie's Emilio have a tattoo I do
have a tattoo of getting it removed I
don't like tattoos love tattoos on other
people it freaks me out that it's in my
skin I thought I always wanted a tattoo
and I don't want one anymore and hers
are so nice and mine it's just like
it's not me it's a cloud it's on my arm
I know it's not big I know I'm being
dramatic but I look it's like getting
smaller than I remember no it's fading I
have 15 tattoos I'm getting more when I
get back to LA though my first tattoo
um there was we were at a friend's house
I get a call from Charlie and she's like
I'm getting a tattoo and we're roommates
and we just started living together I'm
like my mom and dad are gonna blame me
for her like doing this and I'm feel
responsible so I get to the house and
I'm like Charlie are you sure you want
to do this I have to be all big sister
and then I had already asked my parents
and they said yes but no one told me
that so I was freaking out and I felt
responsible but it's really cute and
everyone like made a really big deal out
of it but it's just like a smiley face
that's another reason why I guess I'm
not kid-friendly 60 demilio sweater no
I'm sorry
I curse a lot
um
yeah it's bad
sorry I don't know I feel like I do it a
lot but I'm good at censoring myself
sometimes on tour this summer
I was singing The Last Song and it has
two curse words at the very end and the
security brought up to like little girls
up to the stage and I was staring at
them like I really can't curse right now
and I didn't does Dixie demilio speak
Spanish
see no I'm just kidding I don't know
I've never taken Spanish I took French
for like six years but
I don't remember it she did too no
nothing
thank you so much wired it's Dixie and
Charlie and we had the best time
answering your questions about us thank
you guys bye
[Music]